[Música]
yo no quiero aparecer más ahí le dijo la
niña esto lo cuenta la madre la actriz
argentina griselda siciliani en
televisión fuera un local de ropa nos
llegaron la vendedora saludó la madre o
la margarita cómo está la garita que
tengas un lindo día cuando era niña de 6
años consultó a la madre porque una
desconocida vendedora de un local de
ropa sabía su nombre está le dijo que
probablemente era producto de las
historias que subía a instar a la cadena
con mucha claridad le dijo yo no quiero
aparecer más ahí
hace unos años durante varios días todos
hablamos de lo mismo de la siesta de
nordelta una señora que en un audio de
whatsapp hacía comentarios
al menos polémicos quejándose de los
pocos códigos de estética moral y
estética visual que tenían los vecinos
que tomaban mate en la pileta compartida
los medios lo llamaron el agua vital del
año nadie lo llamó para una conversación
privada entre una persona y su agente
inmobiliario
este tipo de situaciones de
conversaciones privadas o audios de tap
que se filtran a los medios y se vuelven
noticia o se viraliza se volvieron
totalmente cotidianas y son cada vez más
frecuentes sin ningún tipo de debate
sobre por qué discutimos públicamente
conversaciones privadas
no se trata sólo de la vitalización o de
los famosos esto aplica en otros ámbitos
también otras historias
hace unos años hice un viaje de
capacitación éramos 30 o 40 personas que
durante una semana compartimos distintos
talleres de distintas capacitaciones me
acuerdo que en un momento una chica me
pide que le sacó una foto con otros
participantes y media el celular y yo
creo que está bloqueado entonces le dio
lo puedes desbloquear por favor así te
saco la foto y ella ya esos tres metros
ubicadas para la foto medio que me grita
te paso la contraseña no me molesta que
la tengas algo que yo me acerque un
poquito más le dije a mi mujer está
tener tu contraseña
y otras historias otras situaciones un
domingo cualquiera
en el almuerzo familiar muchos se ríen
del grupo de whatsapp de papá con sus
amigos que se pasan pornografía todo el
día como si fueran adolescentes
muy gracioso salvo que la mayoría de
esos vídeos son compartidos sin el
consentimiento de sus protagonistas
en ese mismo almuerzo otra pareja de la
familia le sacó una foto a su nena
recién nacida y la sube a internet la
sube a las redes sociales la beba tiene
tres meses ya tiene su perfil de
instagram tiene decenas de fotos
publicadas en internet y decenas o más
de seguidores un estudio de la
organización para él son la organización
británica para el show dice que los los
menores cuando llegan a los cinco años
tienen alrededor de mil fotos publicadas
en internet mil fotos en cinco años 200
fotos por año 16 por mes 4 por semana
una foto cada 2 días
la familia moderna en línea cuando elegí
este dato se me ocurriera a ver si yo
tenía mil fotos publicadas en internet y
no llegó
a mis 35 años tengo menos fotos
publicadas en internet que la mayoría de
los niños y niñas de 5 años del mundo a
pesar de que nunca tomaron una decisión
sobre su participación en las redes no
se trata solamente de las personas de
los individuos de las familias esto
también afecta al estado también afecta
a las empresas hoy a la mañana en un
hermoso horario de sábado las ocho y
media la mañana recibí un llamado
telefónico cualquier persona arrancando
el fin de semana sin desayunar seguro
estamos todos deseando lo mismo que es
cambiarnos de compañía de celular me
suena el teléfono y un amigo cordobés
con mucha amabilidad me ofrece una
promoción para que me pueda cambiar de
proveedor le dije que me sonaba
interesante que estaba dispuesto a
avanzar siempre podía primero contar de
dónde sacaron mi número telefónico y
quién les dio el consentimiento para
llamarme a la hora que se les cante
esto también aplica al estado ni hablar
organismos públicos que tienen datos de
los ciudadanos datos personales son
muchas veces utilizados por los
funcionarios para fines personales o
políticos tenemos el dato el nombre del
dni el teléfono de una persona bueno
debemos nos a base de datos y usemos lo
para hacer una campaña o una encuesta
política telefónica y si no los atienden
ya que tenemos los datos porque nos los
afiliados al partido
los datos están ahí porque no usarlos
las empresas los usan los comparten y
hasta a veces los venden porque para
ellos son datos no son ni personales ni
privados
solamente datos podría seguir todo el
día hablando de esto y como ya verán
estas historias tienen un patrón común
que es la privacidad de eso les quería
hablar hoy de la imperiosa necesidad que
discutamos como sociedad cuanto nos
importa tener una vida privada porque a
priori pareciera ser que no tanto la
privacidad es el derecho que tenemos las
personas a que nuestra vida esté
resguardada por la confidencialidad es
decir que podamos decidir quién es en
qué momento y qué cosas se sepan de
nuestra vida nuestras acciones nuestras
decisiones nuestras opiniones la
declaración universal de los derechos
humanos dice que es un derecho humano su
artículo número 12 dice que la vida
privada es un derecho humano y es
interesante que no es un derecho humano
tan antiguo de hecho es más bien un
derecho humano moderno hasta hace un par
de siglos para atrás no era tan raro que
la gente se cambie se bañe o hasta tenga
sexo a delante de otras personas
hoy sin embargo es impensado que se dé
una ducha delante de otras personas sin
que eso es una decisión es claramente un
hecho privado
a pesar de que las computadoras de
internet tienen más de 30 años yo creo
que la última mitad de los últimos 10 o
15 años esto se ha puesto más evidente a
partir del surgimiento de plataformas o
tecnologías que realmente ponen en jaque
a la privacidad
smartphones cámaras conectividad redes
sociales big data son distintos términos
que de una u otra forma modifican cómo
nos comportamos con los datos con los
datos personales con los datos privados
y nos invitan a repensar este concepto
de la privacidad
la realidad es que en estos 15 años a
pesar de esos cambios los debates
alrededor de la privacidad no han sido
tantos
quizás cambie un poquito o un pequeño
punto de inflexión el año pasado cuando
fue el escándalo entre facebook y con
facebook y cambridge analítica escándalo
que terminó así
mark zuckerberg el dueño y fundador de
la red social más grande del mundo
sentado atrás con una transmisión en
vivo por internet y todos los medios de
comunicación ahí frente al congreso de
los eeuu dando explicaciones sobre cómo
su empresa utilizaba los datos
personales de los usuarios las redes
sociales se han vuelto una parte
fundamental del entramado de la
privacidad moderna estas son las
condiciones de uso de las redes sociales
que más utilizamos a su derecha tiene la
snap chat a la izquierda tiene a
instagram nuestra privacidad no puede
depender de que leamos estos textos y al
mismo tiempo cuánto les podemos exigir a
las empresas de redes sociales al fin y
al cabo son empresas tiene que haber
probablemente algún equilibrio entre su
responsabilidad y su necesidad de hacer
negocios equilibrio que probablemente
estemos aún buscando
pero mientras tanto es importante que
pensemos cómo actuamos nosotros y como
entendemos y pensamos a las redes
sociales
veamos cómo salimos pensarlas esto que
está acá es una transacción comercial
tradicional bien creo que todos vemos
que hay un cliente un usuario hay un
proveedor
hay un producto o podría ser un servicio
y por supuesto hay que pagar por ese
producto o servicio
como solíamos ver las redes sociales o
al menos mayoritariamente hay un
proveedor bien y un usuario
ese proveedor facebook por citar un
ejemplo podría ser cualquier empresa o
cualquiera de estas redes sociales bien
estas empresas nos dan un producto las
aplicaciones el servicio de las redes
sociales bien y por suerte son gratuitas
entras te registras y las usas es genial
tenemos servicios geniales y además son
gratuitos
ahora son gratuitos
si dijimos que son empresas y que ganan
dinero de jove el dinero son
organizaciones sin fines de lucro hay
una visión un tanto evolucionada esta
idea que lamentablemente a pesar de que
quizás para muchos de ustedes en este
momento suena obvio que no
lamentablemente es la idea más común
usemos las redes sociales que son gratis
pero hay una idea un tanto evolucionada
que es que nosotros usamos las redes
sociales pero que no son gratis que las
pagamos con nuestros datos
muchos habrán escuchado alguna vez las
redes sociales no son gratis las pagas
con tus datos
insisto que a pesar de que es una idea
evolucionada sigue siendo un tanto
incompleto a fin de mes las empresas les
pagan a sus usuarios el sueldo con datos
los accionistas buscan ganar datos
evidentemente no son empresas que ganan
mucho dinero y que valen mucho dinero
entonces intentemos verlo al revés hay
un proveedor bien de redes sociales
insisto facebook es un ejemplo y hay
alguien que paga dinero que les da el
dinero y el que paga el dinero es
siempre el cliente si el que paga el
dinero es el cliente evidentemente el
cliente de facebook y otros servicios
basados en anuncios son los anunciantes
son las empresas que pagan para tener
anuncios en estos servicios y está
perfecto que así sea porque es su modelo
de negocios ahora si nosotros no somos
el cliente que el lugar nos queda en
esta imagen nosotros somos la zanahoria
nosotros somos el producto las redes
sociales no son gratis ni las pagamos
con nuestros datos nosotros somos el
producto y en el mejor de los casos
nuestros datos es la materia prima pero
así hacen dinero a las redes sociales y
así las tenemos que entender en el medio
de este circo nosotros bailamos y
exponemos nuestras vidas privadas en
estos servicios y empezamos a perder el
límite entre lo privado y lo público y
vivimos con la ilusión de que esa vida
privada que exponemos en internet nunca
va a ser usada en nuestra contra
de lo que hagan las empresas y sus
prácticas que por supuesto que es
importante de lo que haga el estado con
sus leyes y controles pero
fundamentalmente lo que hagamos nosotros
con nuestros hábitos va a depender hacia
dónde va la privacidad en un futuro y
qué lugar va a ocupar en la sociedad que
queremos vivir
déjenme contarles
una historia más
muchas veces en el trabajo en reuniones
de amigos surge el debate sobre si
nuestras parejas tienen o no la
contraseña en nuestro celular
el debate relativamente moderno a la
mínima que uno dice que no al menos en
un grupo de hombres en la era moderna
hay una hay una respuesta
lamentablemente sale esta respuesta que
es eso es un pirata no compartís tu
celular incluso te podría ser el debate
entre una pareja discutiendo si
realmente van a compartir o no el acceso
a un dispositivo personal
pensemos un segundo que se esconde
detrás de esta idea
solo si eso es una mala persona tienes
derecho a la privacidad este es uno de
los mitos más grandes que hay alrededor
de la privacidad
que solamente aquel que tiene algo que
ocultar tiene derecho a la privacidad y
este día es terrible no pensar a la
privacidad como el humano derecho a
tener una intimidad a elegir que
queremos que se sepa y que no y que no
necesariamente todo eso sea algo malo
hay una dicotomía con esta problemática
que está muy bien representada en una
frase del libro mil 984 de george orwell
que dice hasta que no tengan conciencia
no podrán rebelarse
pero si no se revelan nunca van a tener
conciencia
algo muy similar pasa con la privacidad
los responsables de que tomemos
conciencia sobre la importancia de la
privacidad son las empresas el estado
los medios que son los mismos que se ven
beneficiados si nosotros no cuidamos
nuestros datos personales y no nos
importa nuestra vida íntima
para cerrar los invito a hacer un viaje
piensen cada uno un destino al que les
gustaría viajar algún lugar lindo que
conozcan el desencanto que no conozcan
bien lejano tiene que ser lejos tenemos
que ir en avión está imaginen cuánto
quieren conocer ese lugar imagínense
preparándose para el viaje llegando al
aeropuerto subiéndose el avión listos
para despegar la emoción que nos implica
viajar es el lugar la alegría de que
vamos a volver a conocer ese lugar por
primera vez despega el avión ya estamos
en viaje con todo lo que implica irnos
de vacaciones y nueve viajes alegría
emoción y cuando estamos en el aire ya
volando nuestro compañero de la derecha
nuestra compañera de la izquierda nos
miran nos sonríen ponen la mano en el
bolsillo y sacan un atado de cigarrillos
se prende en un cigarrillo cada uno y
así cada uno de los 300 pasajeros del
avión se va aprendiendo no sólo uno sino
todos los cigarrillos que quieran en las
próximas diez horas de este hermoso
viaje que estamos haciendo
pero ya no parece tan hermoso ese viaje
con el humo arriba dentro del avión no
esto mismo me pasó a mí hace unos pocos
meses estaba mirando una serie situada
en la década del 60 donde los
protagonistas fumaban arriba del avión
como así también en reuniones de trabajo
o en lugares cerrados
estoy casi seguro que cualquiera de
ustedes tendría una reacción si ahora
alguien acá se prende un cigarrillo
adentro del auditorio
sin embargo no hace tanto que esto
cambio
hace 20 años cuando se creó google
todavía se podía fumar en algunos
aviones comerciales
hace 15 años cuando se creó facebook en
argentina todavía se podía fumar en
lugares cerrados y en restaurantes
sin embargo hoy ya nos parece
descabellado cuando las cosas cambian
parecen obvias pero ese cambio a veces
es muy lento
yo espero que ese sea el camino lento
que hagamos con la privacidad pero que
tenemos que dar el tiempo y los debates
necesarios para que como yo siempre digo
sea cómodo el péndulo entre el lugar que
tuvo la privacidad concebida la era
moderna en los últimos dos siglos y el
valor casi nulo que parece que le damos
a la privacidad los últimos diez o
quince años y que ojalá y depende mucho
de nosotros eso sea cómodo en algún
lugar intermedio donde probablemente la
red definamos pero sí insisto sobre todo
la cuidemos
y que la privacidad sea el cigarrillo
del futuro y que quien dice que el día
de mañana en muchos años algún hijo o
algún nieto de mi generación pueda decir
pensar que a mi papá le hicieron un
perfil de instagram cuando era bebé y
todo el mundo miraba sus fotos qué
locura
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]